she does look like she's older and got a
little bit more of that bite you know
what I'm saying
what you mean
[Music]
welcome back to another Chaotic episode
of careful boys we have with us Mr
Walter Hong oh hello Walter we have
Colleen Wong we have Nick Nick Hong Bart
Guam Anthony Lee hide your stomach what
I'm talking about belly tiger stomach
actually that's what Joe called me
Anthony Wong when he was trying to spell
JK news with acronyms he didn't have a
[ __ ] l in there so he called me
Anthony that's right oh he really called
you Anthony wants
[Music]
is JK isn't Just J for jitsukawa and K
for Quan it's also n for Nick e for Ryan
email
W
for Anthony Wong yeah
s is for Steve Steve he's the S now you
really made that one work that was very
um misleading uh anyways what's up
Walter did you color your hair you look
young you know um oh I do yeah
Backstreet is back on all right yeah but
this is I always uh ask my color is to
wreck like just pick a color and then so
she's like I think a gold would be good
I was like okay cool why she goes
because it hides your Grays better like
you can keep it in longer because if I
do like let's say like a black my roots
my gray roots will show yeah so I have
to color it more frequently which is
like if you do gold then you can just
keep going for a little bit longer I
don't think she knows what she's talking
about really you can still see grace
yeah a few well there's Grace on the
side yeah on the side yeah yeah how many
how is that supposed to cover this one's
like a month my hair grows fast that's
not bad though yeah my hair grow like if
if I had the wherewithal I would cut my
hair every two weeks
but I don't have the wear with it you
don't want you don't like the Silver Fox
look you don't want to just you know I
think if I if I was single I mean I'm
sorry no if I had was I was married and
had kids yeah and I had the opportunity
to say like f the kids like some people
then I probably would leave it as a
silver fox yeah but no some people being
single you know I don't want to mention
anyone's names who said f the kids but
you know
oh you mean bar I'll give you their
initials bar Quan yeah so okay nice but
yeah no if I I think if I was like
married or I had like a long-term
girlfriend I probably wouldn't care as
much but I'm really shallow so like I
feel like I need to not be gray so if
you were dating a woman who did have
gray hair would that be a problem did
you throw her in the garbage
I'm sure I'd want to at times to throw
in the garbage but it wouldn't be for
the gray hair so much yeah yeah just for
other stuff but you know there is a
thing though you know how like that
silver hair is like trendy right now
yeah
you always wanted that but then I feel
like if I get it they're not gonna be
like oh that guy's cool he's got he's
got silver hair you're like oh that
guy's old be like that guy knows some
spells
he's got the Warlock
that's pretty good you know I think it
would look pretty cool with all gray
hair right yeah I think so but I don't
know to be fair
from my perspective right now it's just
gray it's just gray now I saw the
peaking of the the uh gold I believe um
but you know what you're not hiding in
Gray but you still look great oh thank
you are you usually a hat guy
um when I go at home I'm not
but when I go out I step out I'll wear a
hat because I feel like I've only seen
you here with a hat yeah and like people
tell me like they're like when I take my
head like oh you have hair and I'm like
well yeah it doesn't everyone yeah
doesn't everyone but then I realized
yeah not everyone yeah not Steve Green
geez oh sorry I shouldn't say his last
name not Steve G
officials Steve Green
because that's pretty impressive no it's
it's just it's all like but the funny
thing is is like my close friends
half of us have a full head of hair yeah
and the other half have sparse hair so
it doesn't really occur to me that
people are balding or so much until like
I go out into the wild and then I'll see
like other people my age and I'm like oh
okay that's not like what I look like
yeah like I don't notice you know you
don't notice until you go out and
because I've been at home for the past
three years like I don't really go out
well I think people can hide it better
in the early stages anyway like true you
know like there's I've had friends who
started losing it mid-20s but they you
had no clue yeah transitions key like
it's you know some people they had gray
hair from college yeah they they didn't
transition and then as they got older it
just stayed gray so now if they color it
everyone's gonna be like yo what
happened what'd you do but like I
transitioned as soon as I saw enough
gray I started coloring my hair so that
now if you do see Graves people like oh
you have gray hair and then I'm like oh
yeah I always had a lot but I have gray
hair coming in yeah white hair yeah all
over my head yeah so as soon as you
start getting up top and you it gets to
the point where you notice it right away
yeah then you start coloring and no one
will be the wiser like they'll just
think you always have black hair is
pretty black if I don't gel my hair
though you'll see a lot
but then I also feel too lazy to like
color hair I really like that Viral like
Tick Tock video of that like Chinese
dude or whatever who's like kind of got
he's bald but he has all of his like
little toupees that are just on yeah
yeah it really switches and he's like
dancing around but he like takes off
Troll and throws it on and then he takes
and he throws it off and takes another
one officially like throws it off but it
[ __ ] looks good like instant changing
yeah like the minute it goes on it's
like it doesn't look fake at all even
though you see like six other patches on
him when he takes off he's got like the
cut that comes right here and it's
perfectly like just shaved off and then
he takes it off and he takes the next
thing he puts it on but it's like
Flawless and it's like six different
full-on styles it's a like emo it's like
a full lock it's like a [ __ ] but it's
crazy that might arguably be the best
presented like in terms of like looks
that style of like you shave this off
and then you just get a different hair
piece that you glue on that's tight
that's probably the most convincing but
it's probably not the most sustainable
because it costs a lot the thing with
toupees or like hair plugs or anything
is for the people that know you it's
going to be a huge change yeah they're
not going to be used to it they're going
to stare at you constantly but the
people that don't know you they're the
ones that are gonna be none the wiser
because I have a friend's dad that got
hair plugs or some some procedure done
could not stop staring
couldn't because for the lives because
you know the old hymn I know the old
Hymn for like 20 30 years yeah but then
all of a sudden he's got hair and
everything all looks great I'm like I I
can't get beyond the fact that he used
to be bald it just doesn't it doesn't
click some people look good bald too
that's true like when you know people
bothering and they just go [ __ ] it and
they shave the rest and they uncover
this amazing nicely shaped head like
Jordan dude yeah like Jordan what if
Jordan had [ __ ] hair all of a sudden
and he brought back like a little Hitler
mustache too yes he did yes he did Bald
a little stash like LeBron should just
accept it LeBron should just accept dude
talk about you're just going bald LeBron
needs to go bald yeah but he won't
because he looks great well you know
he's got a great head yeah but you know
but every guy every guy has their thing
that makes me feel vulnerable yeah
actually that's true because you know
LeBron you know you've seen the headband
memes where like it started here like
teens and then
for a while looked really good but then
it just you know well yeah once the
cul-de-sac kind of forms too much though
yeah it gets rough but I think that's a
big thing too because a lot of the time
it's mental for men it's not so much
that they look bad it's just the feeling
of like your age is is catching up with
you in a visible way but you know again
it doesn't always look that bad but then
there is a lot of solutions I don't know
which ones work but I do know because
you know dietrich's got that done yeah I
like that he shows it too yeah he's the
only person that can because he has that
[ __ ] sense of humor so like my friend
who's going bald very early age uh
eventually just said [ __ ] it and went to
one of those treatments where they they
shave it and then they glue a piece but
then you have to change it every like
month or so because it that the hair
falls out of that too oh wow so your
[ __ ] wig goes to re-glue every month
you get it well almost because it
depends on if you have like uh for some
guys that don't really do a lot of
physical activity you don't have to
change as often because you don't sweat
but then if you do sweat that's the
thing that makes the glue come up and
then your hair just starts doing this
yeah so he can't shower with it on you
can shower yeah but it's it's sweating
is underneath yeah it's more about
what's happening on your skin underneath
the hair piece yeah so is itch do you
ever see them go off oh yeah it'll super
itch afterwards [ __ ] found out I've
been searching this whole time for this
video what is it oh all right here we go
ready it's this guy bug the other one
oh wow
look at that pulls it back off grabs
another one look how fast this is
don't know what Flawless whoa he looks
good in all kinds of hairstyles right
seriously dude keep watching get out of
here why is Janice texting look at it
hey who's Leslie
look at that look at that not [ __ ]
sick
look at that [ __ ] damn everything looks
good on it everything looks flawless
stop laughing Ryan how do you know dude
stop laughing dude
because it's like something a kid would
do like
oh no not to [ __ ] say that
so that's the same thing that Dietrich
has he has that thing where he can he
can do that too wow but the crazy thing
is they'll because you know you're never
really gonna lose this side here so they
leave that and they'll fade it up to a
point and that's where the stuff fits in
but again do you guys like play games
with it do you like I'm sit up there and
you're just like all the time toss it
over like it's funny because once it
starts getting loose and it's time for
him to change it he'll just like [ __ ]
around go walk and then flip up like
it's really funny or it'll be like hey
smell it and then oh God and it's it's
pretty [ __ ] funny
but I think that's that's why the place
that he went to like fell in love with
him because he made them this like
amazing deal that they could not [ __ ]
refuse to like partner with him on this
piece because he was like hey check it
out I'm gonna actually be the only
client that can tell people I got this
done
because anyone who comes through there
it's a top secret thing you're not even
supposed to see other guys that walk in
this place because you know it's super
confidential but he's like hey guess
what I can do that because I think it's
funny and he made like a whole video
explaining it and we filmed the whole
process thinking that one day we might
do that that's a good way to cope too it
is yeah a transition into just this new
identity of just this is you know part
of who you are now and I always forget
myself like I always forget that it's a
it's a air piece because it just looks
so you just get you know after a while
you stop thinking about it and you're
like oh [ __ ] oh yeah until he's [ __ ]
around and going like this
in his most comfortable State like let's
say he booked uh uh like a one week
vacation in like the Maldives or
whatever and he's not gonna see anyone
in his most comfortable state would he
be like [ __ ] it I'm not gonna have this
[ __ ] because it itches or whatever not
just be like all natural for a whole
week or would he want to still like look
good like that's his it depends on what
time of the month because if he just got
it on it's easier to just leave him oh
but then if you have to change it after
a while then he'll probably just have it
off and wear hats maybe but God I see I
think it's more like if it's already on
there and the glue is fresh and it's
just been applied it's not going to come
off you swim you do anything you can
really live life normal like he'll do
head spins it'll be fine
that's a good marketing commercial for
it it really is yeah is he single no
he's not no he's not okay no yeah I was
curious for myself but also I was
curious um in that does he feel like
when he goes out to meet women does he
feel more confident with it on or like
what's the results of it like if it's on
or off he's he got that done in the
middle of already being in a
relationship so he's never even tested
it out on you know he's never Road
tested on the new Mark maybe he should
maybe he should just get out of his
relationship real quick to test his wig
when we should give him a pass like a
case this is for research for the other
men out there yeah I mean I think
judging from some of the guys that I did
see while I was in there because I went
with him to do it and I saw like other
dudes that have just the most
unbelievable pieces like they're so like
old yet they have like the nicest quaff
and it's like way too advanced I'm like
there's not believable yeah there's like
yeah there's I think I think you're
given the power like you just go too
crazy maybe you get the hair you always
wanted which necessarily you shouldn't
kick in good for them come on dude good
for them yeah and I think it's like live
it up but also at the same time let's
like make kind of a believable thing so
it doesn't work against you in the
future I agree women are gonna laugh at
that [ __ ] too they're not idiots you
know yeah even though yeah it looks good
but also it looks a little comical for
sure
we as people ever been like let's just
do just enough I know that's true if the
excess is available you'll take it it
looks like women when they get boob jobs
like when they ask their friends like
what should I get B no no just go double
D because you're going to want to get
bigger anyway and then it's like this 95
pound girl with like triple D or
whatever I don't know the size is and
then and like can you tell that they're
fake no I couldn't
at least they can go like they can do a
modest amount and then just add as they
go now rather than like commit to like
yeah [ __ ] something that doesn't even
have a battery size yeah that's why it's
all about transition transition yeah
that's important uh I relate to that in
like for example getting like tattoos
right just like obviously earlier I'm
just like I'm just gonna get this little
thing but like some of my friends who
are like full sleeves when I was not
even close to being able to get a sleep
you know what I mean they're like dude
you're gonna get a whole sleep anyway
dude you're just planning out the whole
sleep right now like don't [ __ ] plan
out a whole sleeve right now so just
over the years you start getting like
little in here you know it's almost like
Patchwork you get a little Memento here
next thing you know you're like oh I I
want to fill it up more because now it's
got weird [ __ ] and I accept the fact
that I was wrong now because I'm like oh
I ended up getting kind of like a whole
more or less a whole sleeve but at the
time when you're younger you're like I'm
not gonna [ __ ] get a whole sleeve
right now you know I'd rather take it
slow so but I I get that mentality when
you're looking at something you're like
you might as well just commit to it all
the way because you're gonna change it
anyway later you could have also made a
terrible decision when you were younger
to get a full sleeve that was just not
your style as you go that's true that's
good that you did it incrementally yeah
otherwise you'd have a [ __ ] Playboy
Bunny or something dumb [ __ ] or like
lift laugh love that would be so whack
or like you got like the you got like
the white biker
um dragon as opposed to like the Asian
Dragon
they have different they have different
styles you know like the eagles are
different for like yeah the ones that
are like vintage flash yeah so like when
you're because I've already I've been in
high school that got like the the white
biker like I don't know if it was an
eagle some animal on his back and I was
like dude you're gonna you're gonna
regret that you're gonna regret that and
of course two three years later he
regretted it and he got it covered up
yeah into like a I think you got like a
white dry or something else and then he
did this guy that the tattoo artist was
like a real artist and changed it uh
into an oriental Dragon
it made it look really cool
um but we're like you got lucky you
found that guy otherwise because he got
it like I think when he's like 16 or
something yeah that's a couple years
later so I think you know it starts to
like bleed through and
yeah but yeah I it's I could see both
sides though like how you you do want to
plan it out but at the same time you
don't know if you're gonna like any of
the stuff yeah and you're younger you
know what I mean you're not thinking
about like this full-on life commitment
and your agents you're like my mom's
gonna whoop my ass you know what I mean
but it's not until after you you get
like six or seven tattoos and you're
like oh she's not gonna kill me I can
survive this there's also that thing
kind of didn't make sense remember when
we were very young and Tattoos weren't
as common and the one thing I always
heard was like don't get a tattoo
because when you get older it's going to
look stupid it'll fade it'll get all
wrinkly that's not true for anybody like
old dudes with tattoos look [ __ ]
bottles
only because I was at a wedding recently
and the guy that got married is like 45
46. so everyone at the wedding is in
their 40s late 40s early 50s and then I
turned to my friend and then you know
women and they're wearing dresses at the
wedding
um like strapless and like open or
whatever and I turned to my friend I go
hey now I know what it looks like when
you have a tattoo 20 years later and
some of them tattoos did not age well
because they probably got it when they
were like 18 19 and now they're in their
40s it's just oh like the picture itself
yeah or like a [ __ ] stamps
it just didn't like um yeah like trap
snaps didn't really just retain their
value or the detail just starts meshing
yeah and I'm sure their bodies went
through different transformations of
like they went chubby fat and then
skinny I mean they all look great
physically don't even know they all look
great but they're tattoos I don't think
like held up yeah they didn't like take
the journey with them some years they
were like nah play yeah we're just gonna
stop right here and so and then like
when I tell my friends that like I even
told girls this and they started
laughing because you could see everyone
with their tattoos yeah and it's like oh
I feel like that mainly is the case for
like aesthetic tattoos so you know
obviously some people get like art on
their body and stuff yeah I think um
somebody told me a long time ago when I
was trying to get comfortable with the
idea of getting tattoos and they were
like
um it's cool to look at every like your
body is kind of like a journal and then
your tattoos on your body is like your
journal entries you know what I mean you
wouldn't just like throw a sticker in
there that has like no meaning yeah yeah
um so it doesn't really matter what it
looks like because if you look back at
the journal entry you'll know the the
context whether where you were who you
were with the the idea the philosophy
behind it you know what I mean if your
body's a canvas so I think having that
kind of foundation of understanding why
makes it feel better or at least so that
you don't feel weird validating why you
got this dumbass tattoo when you're a
kid and now you're like 50 you know what
I mean at least this meant something
because versus uh it was cool at the
time you know what I'm saying no like
it's like yeah you get a hummingbird on
your lower back and now it looks like a
chicken but it's significant to you
and then something also go to a good
artist yes I think that's the most
invest in the right artist that's the
part about getting tattoos when you're
young is you don't even know who the
best one is yet you can't even afford
the best yeah you're just going to want
to open 300 an hour nah or the one that
doesn't make you bring a side note from
your mom yeah
like you guys know Eunice kiss
she's like a model singer
she's one of the girls at the wedding
and then she's like Oh you mean like
mine hers is on her forearm but it's not
even straight it's like at an angle and
she's like this guy started tattooing at
our church and I was like 15 or 16 and
he just was doing it as a test so I got
it done I'm like oh your mom must have
been so happy because it's not even like
straight and you guys know hyori from
Korea like yeah yeah yeah she's got
tattoos like um as she got to the point
where she was like I don't get tattoos
because Korea when tattoo was back then
were a little weird
she's got tattoos like on her arms I
think she has a sleeve now almost but
they weren't arranged properly so
whatever has lines they're not parallel
to her arm they're like at an end the
placement's off yeah like it should go
with with your body Contour or your body
yeah and like if it's gonna be like off
it should be like really off so it's
like oh there's a statement but hers are
like slightly off so they don't match
and it's like and she's like at one
point uh even still probably now known
as like the hottest sexiest woman in
Korea like ever you know
um and now she's got I co-signed that by
the way yeah
at that time when I was younger oh my
gosh
h-y-o-r-i-l-e-e oh my god oh yeah I
remember her yeah so she's like 40s I
think like especially like in junior
high early High School
I remember this person yeah yeah but now
she's got like it's not arranged in the
place was the art form of tattooing also
evolves too that's true yeah
oh yeah she's so pretty
yeah
and they got all hot for a second
and then her husband now is like not
like and in Korea they don't but she has
a sleeve now almost like a sleeve can we
get a picture of her tattoos I'm sure
they have yeah if you type in shorty
chat too and the thing is her husband is
like not a good looking man and in Korea
they don't have a problem with saying
people are ugly so when she got married
like oh this guy's ugly he's a musician
he's a musician they just say that like
in the newspaper they'll say stuff like
that yeah it's not they're not like
they're very comfortable with saying
stuff like that even though they'll go
home and cry about it they're
comfortable telling people oh yeah she's
ugly like I don't think she's pretty
they're comfortable saying that but
they're all going home and crying man
just like it's like and he just needs to
go shave his chin but she's got more now
no this is probably this is old yeah
this is a little older she's got more
she does look like she's older and got a
little bit more of that bite you know
what I'm saying
[Music]
she been through some [ __ ] you know
and then her husband's in the tattoos as
well so they both they're both we don't
need to talk about her husband
[Music]